alors bonjour à tous pour ce qui est un
peu sur les informations en 2019 en mars
2009 plus précisément il y avait la
marge pour climat et je m'étais rendu
avec des copines à moi qui était plus ou
moins activistes donc on y était allé
vous savez que les panneaux avec les
jeux de mots et après la manifestation
s'étaient tous rendus au mac do ba pour
manger parce qu'on n'est pas les budgets
chacun c'était le fast food le plus
proche en fait finalement de l'amont été
et en m'asseyant
je regarde autour de moi et je vois donc
les plateaux avec l'emballage avec les
pailles avec les gobelets et mange pas
pour faire un court mais mc do en france
et 115 tonnes d'emballages j'étais
chaque jour et alors moi je manque
énormément de cohérence par contre je te
le bij playlist très très vite alors ya
une question qui met forcément venu à
l'esprit c'est pourquoi
alors qu'on a forcément qu'on a
conscience de l'impératif écologique
pourquoi est ce que on va au fast food
après avoir manifesté et plus largement
aux et notre intelligence
où est notre cohérence ou est où est
notre instinct de survie face à
l'impératif écologique alors j'ai
commencé à répondre à cette question en
mai dans deux revues psychologiques
économiques politiques et plus
j'avançais plus je trouvais un petit peu
des solutions c'est à dire la peur
l'impératif l'urgence la culpabilisation
qui finalement n'était pas forcément les
choses mais j'ai l'impression d'être
finalement une imposture en parlant de
ça alors parce que finalement fait des
moyens pour manipuler les foules afin
que celle ci arrive un projet commun il
y en a il ya des formations des métiers
pour ça il ya un des pathologies alors
je me suis arrêté j'ai honnêtement je
n'ai pas foutu grand chose et une
question c'est finalement encore une
fois imposé à moi c'est pourquoi est ce
que j'aurai envie de sauver la planète
pourquoi est ce qu'on est vraiment
pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait envie de
sauver notre vaisseau comment je sais
que ça fait un peu provoc dit comme ça
mais ça l'est beaucoup moins que ce que
vous êtes en train de penser je vous
rassure
alors j'ai pas venu ici en tant que
scientifique je suis étudiante en droit
qui plus est je suis assez nul en
sciences par contre j'ai dû les travaux
d'un autre scientifique célèbre symbole
heures je vais vous la faire courte mais
je vous incite à regarder sur internet
sans vrai c'est très intéressant dans
notre cerveau il ya ce qu'on appelle le
cortex cingulaire intérieur qui se
présente comme une machine à détecter du
sens et cette petite machine
permet de construire d'autres
représentations du monde mais aussi via
l'uer de l'adéquation de nos actes avec
nos valeurs je grossis lestrem et par
exemple si on se trouve par hasard dans
une situation où la planète qui est
censé nous accueillir puisque ne pas
nous permettre de vivre encore une
centaine d'années alors tu en voilà le
contexte cingulaire antérieur est en
alerte et ctri atom qui va prendre le
relais de traiteur et d'autres parties
du cerveau et le striatum quand il prend
le relais ça va se manifester par une
surconsommation
déjà d'achat compulsif de nourriture de
tabac de drogue de série de films une
pièce et ça nous pousse à long terme la
vie dans une passivité maintenant que
c'était une détresse psychologique et
honnêtement sacrant et sa crainte
d'autant plus parce que au final c'est
un peu comme si vous faites un travail
qui ne vous plaît pas vous allez finir à
vous allez commencer par finalement
faire un travail bâclé qui va pas vous
plaire dans une situation de détresse
psychologique encore une fois et vous
allez ces deux composés par tous les
moyens afin de trouver du sens à votre
vie
alors c'est assez bateau feu me
pardonner je suis jeune là je vais faire
le petit speech jeudi que la société
craint un peu mais
depuis que la révolution industrielle
nous a incités et nous avons pensé à ces
choix nous a aidés finalement à vis dans
le confort est dans le pouvoir
finalement la halle dans la chance de
pouvoir consommer à peu près comme on le
veut on a concédé que la question du
sens de nos vies est assez superflu
était assez superficiel on a assisté est
ce qu'on appelle une marchandisation du
sens et des valeurs ont découlé qui sont
par exemple l'urgence la culpabilité
l'argent est le problème c'est que il ya
un hic c'est qu'on est en train d'être
la planète on est en train de détruire
la planète et on pourrait y remédier en
nous hissant justement ce contexte
angulaire antérieur et là vous vous
étiez mvd des moyens de trop du sens à
votre vie et non j'ai essayé trouver du
sens à la vie j'ai essayé de trouver
d'essayer trouver des moyens d'y accéder
et il ya plusieurs écoles en fait le
simple fait de prendre conscience du de
la planète de vouloir la sauve et
donnerait du sens à nos existences avoir
une appartenance planétaire une vision
commune du monde nous permettrait
d'avoir une action cohérente
cependant je suis étudiante que je vous
ai dit et je suis mieux parler de nous
et premièrement j'ai une question à vous
poser qui d'entre vous a une vision du
sauvetage de la planète menée par des
étudiants un peu enragés qui viendra un
peu bousculé les codes et qui nous
sauverait l'apocalypse bon je vois pas
dire à vos écrans en tout cas c'est ma
vision et c'est la vision de pas mal de
gens de la génération on sent impliquée
dans une cause commune et finalement la
du mal on a du mal à agir dans ce sens
là et j'adorais pourra croire à ce que
j'ai dit plus haut au fait que le simple
fait d'avoir conscience de l'importance
de la planète pourrait nous aider
justement à aller trouver notre place il
ya ait trouvé une action cohérente
cependant
et bien c'est pas le cas c'est pas le
cas et donc pour répondre à cette
question je suis simplement juste
rappelant que ce format sur internet
j'ai tapé tout simplement jeunes et
écologie je suis rampe aller très loin
et je tombais sur un site le site de la
du gouvernement le site sa vie publique
et il ya un article saper les jeunes
sont inquiets pour le climat mais
continue de consommer et je veux dire
quelques passages que je pas n'importe
quoi après je veux pas qu'on m'accuse de
temps apporte le gouvernement mais à la
fin il y avait cinq leviers d'action
pour une consommation plus durables et
en partie montrer les bénéfices
personnels comme par exemple respirer
mieux manger plus sans montrer que les
pratiques durables peuvent être une
manière de s'acharner socialement par
exemple en chine on d'anciens vêtements
pour avoir un style vestimentaire bien
en soit vous apprends rien en disant
qu'on sait déjà et surtout
et surtout selon une étude réalisée par
le credoc le changement climatique et ce
qui inquiète le plus les jeunes en 2019
alors jouer son deuxième site quand même
qu'ici de force donc quand même un gros
site et sur lequel on dîne qui a une
étude qui a été menée par l'institut des
humains sur une deux jeunes de 18 à 25
ans durant un an et on dresse le
portrait d'une jeunesse très
consumériste peu encline à l'effort soit
leur principale source d'information
casse les réseaux sociaux le
rédactionnel à peu de place l'image est
reine et ses eaux là il ya une bon rien
exemple un peu risible l'image est reine
et ses parts elle qu'ils expriment leur
pointe concernant l'ours blanc tout seul
sur son bout de glace à la dérive merci
alors leur principale source
d'information reste du coup et les
réseaux sociaux toutefois elle a le
double inconvénient de rester
superficielle sans profondeur ni remise
en contexte et de se focaliser
uniquement sur ce qui se passe bien en
visuel cela explique la
sur-représentation des animaux exotiques
ou des feux de forêt spectaculaire aux
dépens d'autres sujets plus difficiles a
représenté comme par exemple des
émissions co2 ou les ressources rares
bons swaps' j'ai plusieurs choses la
réponse parce que comme je vous ai dit
je suis pas là vraiment je suis ici pour
parler vraiment de nous et je parle pas
de ceux qui s'y connaissent énormément
en écologie ge parle de des jeunes de ma
génération
le premier point qui me paraît important
a évoqué
c'est que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'il y à déjà une pandémie un chômage
exponentiel
et une crise économique actuelle ou à
venir selon son qu'il dit
est le problème c'est que nous on doit
déjà s'en sortir tous les cinq ans qui
reste à venir il y en a même cinq ans
c'est de la chance parce que ils ont
perdu leur travail ils ont perdu un
travail il doit s'en sortir pour ce qui
se passera demain il est vrai que pour
nous c'est assez compliqué de pouvoir
s'impliquer dans un projet à long terme
quand j'ai le court terme et est
difficile est difficile pour certains et
j'ai de la chance je dans un milieu
privilégié mais honnêtement vous le
savez vous regardez la fondation autant
que moi c'est pas facile c'est vraiment
le deuxième point le deuxième point je
voulais évoquer c'était sur le manque de
culture des jeunes par rapport à
l'impératif écologique dont on se
moquait dans l'article
et j'ai une anecdote à raconter sur ça
c'est que quand je révisais le concours
de sciences po je devais apprendre un
petit peu sur l'écologie donc j'ai fait
un effort je suis la bibliothèque
universitaire et j'ai pris trois livres
dont un qui datait de 2011 sur lequel on
donnait dans lequel on donnait en fait
trois ans pour sauver la planète ce qui
nous renvoyait donc à 2014
et si on rajoute à ça si on rajoute à ça
le fait que la plupart des gens
finalement ne sont pas scientifiques
comme j'ai dit sont par exemple comme
moi ils veulent très grand marché de
l'art ou veulent travailler tout
simplement je sais pas en coiffure ou ou
veulent ou veut faire la cuisine il est
vrai que là les données de nestlé
données d'internet ceux concernant la
culture écologique soit on fourre tout
dans lequel on ne s'y retrouve pas on ne
s'y retrouve pas
et le troisième point le troisième point
que j'aimerais qui pour moi un des plus
important c'est qu'il est vrai que les
jeunes n'ont pas détruit la planète et
il y a un réel sentiment d'injustice le
réel sentiment d'injustice c'est que on
nous critique par rapport au fait qu'on
consomme des choses qui à terme polluent
la planète
certes
mais que finalement nous on en veut
aussi on en veut à ses entreprises
justement polluantes qui nous incitent à
consommer et ont fait étonnant ce qu'on
peu ce qu'on veut avec le budget
d'étudiant qui est déjà bon ça ramène au
premier point au fait que justement
certains ne peuvent pas s'en sortir pour
le lendemain
alors une chose est sûre cependant c'est
qu'on est prêt à aider alors éclairé
nous aider nous on a besoin d'espoir de
visibilité on peut plus faire bande à
part on n'a plus le temps de faire bande
à part alors je sais quand tu as dit que
c'est censé donner des réponses je vais
poser votre question alors
la planète j'ai une chose est sûre c'est
que la planète n'est pas vulnérable nous
le sommes et que cette inaction et satin
cohérence continuera de notre côté
autant de temps que celle des gens qui
doivent nous aider continuera et
persistera cependant un jour on
arriverait à un point de non retour
inévitable
et tous les réponses auxquelles on n'a
pas eu de réponse tous les poulets
question au caire n'a pas eu de réponse
nous mènera une crise qui sera bien
puisque existentielle merci
[Applaudissements]